SCP-173 - It’s one of the most iconic anomalies
ever contained by the SCP Foundation.
This neck-snapping Site-19 celebrity is known
and feared by everyone who works at the Foundation
since being contained in 1993, its nubby,
concrete hands metaphorically, and quite literally,
stained with the blood of countless people.
But this mostly immobile oddity wasn’t always
a resident of Site-19, and the story of how
exactly it ended up there - and more importantly,
why - is far more ridiculous, insane, and
downright terrifying than you could ever imagine.
So buckle up, SCP Fans.
This is the dramatic tale of how this homicidal
piece of modern art ended up at the SCP Foundation’s
largest containment site.
To give you an idea of just how weird this
origin story is, we’re gonna have to leap
forward to the year 2045.
We know what you’re thinking: Isn’t this
a prequel?
How can it take place in the future?
Sit tight, folks, it’ll all make sense in
the end.
Site-91 is where we lay our scene, under the
watchful eyes of Site Director Dr. James Long,
a senior researcher with Level 4 Security
Clearance - the second highest at the Foundation.
Dr. Long had given decades of devotion and
his expertise to the Foundation; he was a
proud man, who wore his life of service to
the containment cause as a badge of honor.
After years of dodging death while researching
some of the most dangerous anomalies that
Site-91 had to offer, he had ascended to the
rank of Site Director which represented the
culmination of his life’s work.
And in his new position of power, he’d only
proved himself further - running a tight ship,
and reducing the number of containment breaches
across the board.
Nobody could say that Dr. Long wasn’t extremely
talented at his job, which is why he was so
confused when he received an email from Alexandra
Nala, an Administrative Assistant working
directly for the O5 Council.
It was the type of email that no Site Director
ever wanted to receive: Dr. Long was being
told that, with no input or oversight from
him, the majority of Site-91’s anomalies
were going to be taken to an undisclosed location
for “Safer Containment.”
The list contained nearly every meaningful
detainee contained on the site, including
of course, SCP-173.
This particular anomaly had been contained
at the site for 37 years after being delivered
there in 2008.
Dr. Long had devised a perfect method to minimize
containment breaches in that time - creating
a sprinkler system within the chamber that
washes away the waste products produced by
173, reducing the need for risky human contact.
But that didn’t matter.
Despite Dr. Long’s loyalty and efficacy
in serving the SCP Foundation, the decision
had already been made, with no chance of reversing
it.
According to Nala, the motion to remove most
of Site-91’s anomalies had received unanimous
approval from the O5 Council, and the operations
for the transfer would be commandeered by
the Department of Extra-Universal Affairs,
headed by Senior Agent Sven Kisch.
Dr. Long was both upset and confused.
He was producing some of the best results
across the entire Foundation, so why were
they taking away all of his anomalies?
Did someone on the O5 Council have it out
for him?
Dr. Long replied to Nala, asking if - considering
how severe the relocation operation was going
to be - whether he could get more information
on where the anomalies were being moved to,
and why.
He felt that, at the very least, he was owed
some answers on this.
Nala and her superiors didn’t feel quite
the same way.
She replied that Dr. Long sadly didn’t have
the clearance to know any of the operation’s
particulars - this information was reserved
for those with Level 5 Clearance, and members
of the Multi-Universal Department.
All that Dr. Long needed to do was stay out
of the way, and everything would be taken
care of for him.
But that wasn’t enough for Dr. Long.
He needed to know more.
He needed to understand why this seemingly
random decision had been made.
Realizing that Nala and the O5 Council were
a dead end as far as information was concerned,
he instead reached out to the next best thing:
Senior Agent Sven Kisch, the member of the
Department of Extra-Universal Affairs who
was spearheading the relocation mission.
Dr. Long implored the Agent to give him extra
information on where all the Site-91 anomalies
were being moved, and why they were being
moved in the first place.
Predictably, he was once again stonewalled,
being told that any information regarding
the project was above his level of clearance.
In a move that seemed decidedly spiteful,
Agent Kisch signed off by saying that he looked
forward to seeing Dr. Long at Site-91.
And not long after that, he did.
Agent Kisch along with a huge number of agents
and task force members from the Multi-U Department
arrived on site, bearing state of the art
containment equipment.
An exasperated Dr. Long wasn’t able to glean
any more information from this experience
- the Multi-U agents were ruthlessly efficient,
transferring the lion’s share of the anomalies
into temporary containment and transporting
them off-site within a few hours.
By the time they were done, Dr. Long and his
staff were left with one of the most desolate
and empty containment sites on the Foundation’s
books.
Here was Dr. Long, with decades of service,
and climbing the organizational ladder, only
to be left as a glorified babysitter for a
handful of low-priority anomalous items.
It all felt like a cruel joke.
After several days of nothing happening in
the now-incredibly-uneventful Site-91, a bored
Dr. Long reached out to a friend of his - Researcher
Nurul Shafiqah binte Ahmad Ibrahim, whom he
called by the nickname Shaq - to vent his
frustrations.
She commiserated, sharing her sympathy for
his suddenly much less exciting working conditions,
but saying that at least the job should be
a little less lethal now.
Shaq didn’t know it yet, but on this particular
point, she was terribly wrong.
Dr. Long shared his theory that perhaps some
sites were being consolidated so the Foundation
could save money, and that this would lead
to layoffs.
Shaq essentially told him that he was worrying
too much.
The reality was that Dr. Long had some very
good reasons to be worried, his problem was
that he hadn’t been worrying about the right
things.
In Foundation Containment Area-179, something
awful was brewing.
As usual, guards posted around SCP-2317 - an
old door containing a portal to another world
- waited while Foundation staff and D-Classes
performed the standard Procedure 220-Calabasas
ritual within.
They were dealing with one of the most dangerous
anomalies in the entire universe, but even
then, after decades of service, one can become
numb to such things.
Suddenly, without warning, the door opened
and a terrified Foundation researcher tumbled
out, panting heavily, eyes bulging in existential
horror.
He screamed the words that he had long hoped
would never be spoken in his or even his children’s
lifetime, “It happened!
The chains have broken!
The Devourer is free!”
The siren sounded, and an alert spread out
across the entire Foundation database: SCP-2317
is compromised, SCP-2317-K - the Devourer
of Worlds - is free.
If the creature escapes Area-179, an XK-Class
End of the World Scenario is basically assured,
so all efforts will be taken to make sure
that the creature does not escape at any cost.
And they really did mean any cost.
The old wooden door of SCP-2317 splintered,
as an immense, scaly hand sprang forth, and
clawed a wave of devastation through the containment
chamber.
Guards were dispatched in the hundreds with
heavy weaponry to buy some time, firing as
the Devourer, a beast the size of a mountain
rose from the ground, staring at the terrified
humans below with its one gigantic red eye.
It couldn’t even feel the bullets, explosives,
or incendiary and laser weaponry being used
on it.
The monster just shrugged it off, and murdered
nearly all its attackers with one swipe of
its claw.
In a final desperate act, hoping to kill or
at least slow down the beast, staff at Area-179
made the ultimate sacrifice, and detonated
the entire on-site nuclear arsenal.
The explosion disintegrated the entire facility
in an instant, and unleashed a radioactive
shockwave that carried destruction for miles.
But it wasn’t enough.
SCP-2317-K walked out of the mushroom cloud
without a scratch on it, ready to show the
human world what real destruction meant.
At this point, the battle was already effectively
lost, but the Foundation refused to go down
without a fight.
They dispatched all available mobile task
forces - including Mobile Task Force Nu-7,
Hammer Down, a heavily-armed, battalion-strength
task force created to combat the biggest and
most extensive threats imaginable.
And it wasn’t even just the Foundation - true
existential threats have a way of uniting
people, as the GOC and even the Chaos Insurgency
temporarily put aside their differences to
take the fight to the Devourer.
But would any of it be enough?
Barrages of cruise missiles and ICBMs did
nothing to halt the Devourer’s assault,
as it rampaged, destroying towns and cities
at first, then regions, then whole nations.
Swarms of scrambled jets and helicopters were
knocked out of the sky with casual swipes.
The creature bulldozed over landscapes teeming
with tanks and heavy artillery vehicles.
It snapped aircraft carriers in half as it
waded from ocean to ocean, systematically
destroying everything in its path.
Even satellite-mounted orbital cannons and
the heavy energy weapons of MTF Tau-5, also
known as "Samsara", did nothing to faze the
Devourer.
It was finally coming to fruition: The dreaded
XK Class End of the World Scenario, and none
of the Foundation’s expertise, advanced
technology, or limitless resources could do
anything to stop it.
They aided in evacuation efforts, getting
as many people as they could out of harm’s
way as the Devourer rampaged and destroyed,
but even that was doing little more than borrowing
time.
Eventually, the Devourer would destroy all
of them.
There would be nothing left.
And all Dr. James Long could do was watch
helplessly from an almost empty Site-91, waiting
for the tide of destruction to reach him.
Of course, other Foundation employees - most
prominently, Senior Agent Sven Kisch and the
Multi-U Department - had other concerns.
All they needed to do was archive data for
extraction.
Extraction to where, you ask, seeing as the
world seems to be at its end here?
Well, Universe 7392-Epsilon-Blue-Lima, otherwise
known as our universe, circa 1993.
The Foundation works across the multiverse,
and an XK-Class End of the World Scenario
in one universe really isn’t necessarily
a problem in others.
On the orders of the O5 Council, Agent Kisch
and his men are charged with extracting data
and valuable anomalies like SCP-173 from doomed
universes.
O5 knew that Dr. Long’s universe - Universe
5643-Gamma-Orange-Delta - was due for an apocalyptic
visit from the Devourer of Worlds any day
now.
That’s why the Multi-U team went in to extract
everything worth saving.
Dr. Long and the millions of other Level-4
and below employees of that universe’s Foundation
were never told of their impending doom.
After all, that sort of thing could probably
lead to unnecessary stress.
And what they don’t know won’t hurt them
- until, of course, it does.
In 1993, these anomalous, doomed universe
SCPs were divided among our universe’s various
applicable containment sites.
SCP-173, as you already know, ended up in
Site-19.
But sadly for the people working there, all
the actual data on this entity’s file was
lost in translation, so as far as they knew,
173 was little more than a big, weird statue
with apparently dangerous properties.
Upon first placing it in its containment chamber
in the Site-19 Euclid Wing, Foundation legend
Dr. Bright, unaware of just what he had here,
assigned Dr. William Motto to begin research
on the entity.
He recommended that the Researcher bring two
D-Classes for testing.
When Dr. Motto was faced with the anomalous
entity’s blank file, he gave a sigh, and
began to write something in its description
box: “Moved to Site-19 1993.
Origin is as of yet unknown…”
Wasn’t that a delightful little tale?
Now we know how SCP-173 made its way into
Site-19, and what our own universe may have
to look forward to in 2045.
So remember, if you ever see Agent Sven Kisch
planning a transfer of anomalies out of your
site, maybe consider using some of that PTO,
and maybe consider putting a downpayment on
a nice, cozy apocalypse bunker over in Iceland…
Know of other tales you’d like to see us
cover?
Let us know down in the comments below!
Now go check out “SCP-001 - When Day Breaks”
and “SCP-1730 - What Happened to Site-13?
The Full Story Compilation” for more terrifying
tales from the SCP Foundation!